this week I've been building not up with
react Jaso is like playing lego
[Music]
I just said the first basic version of
note that so for today let's go today
this up with the notes it's like a short
up to practice and that is that we act
has been changing really quickly I mean
the tutorial was from this year and some
of the some of the comments some of the
methods were outdated I want to style it
a bit more because the basic
functionality is there so I will come
back to it tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
it's wednesday and i'm pretty excited
today because i just found out that
there's first 100 subscribers to my
channel it's really important because
you know I haven't been a mother before
and the aim of this vlog is not to be a
blower but to share the journey to share
the story and to motivate others to
learn to code and also to want to make
myself because I'm taking out a lot from
your feedback from your from your
support the thing is that it's better to
create for people than to create a sorry
for yourself because I also take a lot
of feedback of the motivation a lot of
consonance then you know then a lot of
advice from you I also had some voices
from you that what I show this helpful
is motivating also for you I love
feedback or I'll say it even better I
like feet forward so I don't like feel
back so think that's are just on based
on feelings and they don't get any
reasoning I like feedback or even our
feet forward which is a kind of feedback
that then that gives you also the
justification and makes you move forward
the speed forward is a kind of people
for me that that is aimed to make a
person to whom you give it a developed
to go farther to motivate this person
and I love it so I love this
constructive feedback because it makes
me grow it makes me get motivated even
more to what I'm doing
[Music]
it's Thursday yes daily you know
fighting with fertilizer and my block I
wanted to have no struggle but on mobile
it was a bit of a problem because this
draggable destroyed the functionality of
the buttons that were working on over
it's just yet for me for practicing so I
hope it's enough for now and I will
continue on adding other functionalities
[Music]
today I got greatness to share with you
I was chosen as mentee to tech leaders
problem this is the program organized by
the Polish chapter of women in
technology and I'm really excited to
take part in it so I was chosen from
hundreds of people who wanted to become
a mentee as I mentor I chose ever and i
hope to do it for all ready soon and the
program is totally for free for us and
when it comes to mentees and i will have
four months of wandering man ever and i
want to focus on java spent with her and
I'm really excited because as I where
she is also interested in design and she
also provides a lot in JavaScript so I
hope that these four months will be
really really productive and i hope i
will develop simply faster having this
kind of venture and so it's like a gift
like a gift that I got
[Music]
we have first day in the evening this is
how the app looks right now now you can
drag and drop down notes you can edit
them as you see when they are shorter
they do not have this ellipses here when
they are longer than 30 characters they
gather ellipses so I can drag and drop
the notes i can delete them i can edit
them
[Music]
save the changes I can also clean the
board and AB just only my nose
you
as you see when i add in a note in order
to differentiate it from the crowd it
has got different color but when i added
it the font color is the same as the
rest of notes so this brownish color is
just only for the state when the note
hasn't been changed yet and it's a new
note the new nodes are distributed
randomly so in order to find it in a
huge screen it's better to have a
different color I can clean the board
and I can have just on in my notes on
mobile in the position of the buttons is
an easy to touch areas at the bottom you
can also add an out the lead and out or
edit it with just a Malaysian here but
it shall I mean and and you can clean
the board to make this work I comets--
as few times and get hot this week and I
stuck a little set out of react and
started with setting up the notes and
basic functionalities I started building
this app using the tutorial however i
added also additional functionalities
like cleaning the board for optimizing
the performance or styling it up
differently i also played with set index
of them and because i wanted to make it
more real and if you take something from
the bottom it should appear at the top
if you place it here i will need this
app for the time being of course it can
add a lot of additional functionality
sphere or customization for users but I
won't do it now because the most
important thing in it
was practicing components States and
generally doing the app in Rio she has
this week I was mostly focused on react
Jes and building the note up I was also
doing some challenges for free code camp
math I've been also learning a bit more
about built and installed tools I know
if these much more practice and using in
the project but at least right now I
differentiate them more into to install
and build seven to those who ran the
tasks for you and into those that just
only install the stuff for you some of
them are really complex and I don't need
them right now for my projects that are
quite small but I got a better knowledge
of what is for a walk practice makes
perfect so while using them I hope to
learn the most next week I'm going to
focus on another tutorial connected with
react and I want to build another small
react up in order to practice next week
we are also having their meter of
fronting malaga and i hope to learn a
lot about marrying SVG with d3.js keep
on doing say motivated and see you next
week I almost forgot subscribe
[Music]
Oh